hey guys my name is Jeff I'm Dan and
you're watching games funnies that's it
that's it
[Music]
first up you may have noticed that
player unknowns battlegrounds has
surpassed 1.5 million concurrent users
on Steam oh damn that's a lot that's a
lot of chicken to this just to remind
you dota 2 the previous owner of the
most concurrent players title picked at
one point two nine million in March of
last year dota 2 and pub G are also the
only two games in steams history to pass
1 million peak concurrent players that's
not all though player unknown himself
Brendon Green said in a reddit AMA he'd
love to add a single-player campaign
saying I think the eyelid we have could
be a great location for an interesting
story but unfortunately we just don't
have the time all the resources for this
at the moment he also revealed that
three new vehicles are being to live in
to the island and shared a screen of one
on Twitter check it out pop G is
currently available in early access on
Steam and will make its way to Xbox one
via the game preview program later this
year you may have heard over the weekend
that the Chinese room developers of dear
Esther and everybody's gone to the
rapture is kind of shutting down founder
Dan Pinchbeck confirmed that the studio
was hit with layoffs reducing the
headcount to just three and that they're
going dark at least for now after facing
a health issue in June Pinchbeck said
the team had a very serious think about
things and decided between financial
pressures trying to keep the lights on
for the employed team the stress of end
of development health issues it just
wasn't a tenable thing anymore it was
time to take a break
recharge recover and have a good think
about the future the team's VR fairy
tales so let us melt is the final
finished project at least for now
from the studio Pinchbeck started the
team's hard work saying we did our best
to try and help the team secure new
positions and then we all the whole team
threw everything we had at wrapping the
game it didn't feel fair to anyone least
of all people who had spent a year
working on a project to have its
completion and release overshadowed by
news about the studio closing so we've
held off on the announcement until we
felt we were clear of all of that the
Chinese room or what's left are
currently working on a game called
thirteenth interior and have secured
funding for a new game called a little
Orpheus fingers crossed they can bounce
back after going offline for maintenance
destiny tours back up with an update
that adds fashion rallies update 1.03
has brought the limited time event that
sees you pledging your pew pew services
to one of the three in-game factions for
rewards there's the original emos dead
orbit wipeout cosplay group future war
cult
goody-two-shoes new monarchy after
choosing which faction you want to align
with you'll be rewarded with faction
tokens by completing public events lost
sectors strikes the raid or crucible
matches for your trouble you'll be able
to grab faction specific weapons armor
and shaders
there's also powerful weapons up for
grabs like the dead orbit scout rifle
future war cult
pulse rifle and new monkey sidearm at
the end of the event the faction that
has collected the most reward packages
will see its weapon available to all
players regardless of faction
affiliation for 50000 glimmer while
members of the winning faction will be
able to grab at full 1000
the winner of the faction rally will be
named next week on October 3rd at 10
a.m. don't get to it that is everything
we got a few today do let us know what
you thought of today's stories down in
that comment section and do remember
we'll be back every day of the working
week to let you know what's going on in
gaming
you